all right now um remember what you've
got for your
um your assumption right because that's
what we're gonna um
sub in here in a second um our
assumption was i think you start with k
plus 1 k plus 2 and then you go all the
way up to
2k right that's on the left hand side
and then this looks much the same odd
numbers in here
does that look right yeah that's the
assumption
so now i'm up to step three i'm trying
to actually prove this thing
when i go with the left hand side
uh this is a little bit different to the
previous ones right because before
it's been nice and neat you go like one
two three four five
up to k right and then you've got k plus
one on the end you all you have to do is
take the first terms
but you can't quite do that here can you
right because the first terms here
do not line up with these terms right
can you see my first term over here was
k plus one
my first term over here is not okay so
don't fall into the trap just making a
um a straight substitution even though
this is not the right term
okay that's the kind of thing that we're
looking for to see have you fudged yet
or do you actually know what you're
doing
you've got to do some working around
with this okay
now i should probably include i broke my
own rule 2k
is the last term the need to sub in
right so i might put that here
okay all right so before i can get my
um substitution i'm gonna need to have a
k
plus one out the front here right
i've got to get it in there somehow now
you've sort of got two alternatives to
get it there
so that you can make your substitution
number one
i can just multiply by k plus one and of
course we can't just multiply by things
really nearly right if i've multiplied
by something
to preserve what i had before and have
to
divide right so i could divide the whole
thing by k
plus one okay and then i could
substitute on the top and i could
simplify from there
okay however there's probably a more
direct way
um in this particular example okay so
keep that in mind maybe you want to jot
it down on the side that
multiplying and dividing
is often a useful strategy if what
you've got doesn't look like what you
need to do the switch
okay but here we go
here we actually have a k-plus one it's
just hiding
where is it hiding um
it's hiding here right can you see
there's a k plus one in there it's just
not factorized right yeah
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
start to write out this line
k plus 2 k plus 3 and so on
all the way up to 2k 2k plus 1.
instead of writing this last term i'm
going to write down
2 outside of k plus 1. okay
and now i can bring this it's a is that
right sorry these are all
multiplications aren't they
my bad no i'll pick that up
um maybe you're just being polite i can
now put that back where it belongs at
the start of the product
and then i can do my substitution okay
i generally don't the other day the
phone just fell out and then we put it
back
and i was going to edit it out but i was
like no anyway okay
keep us one out the front and then i've
got the right thing i can switch this
out
multipliers now just watch now because
i've moved that over
um the end of this series will look a
little different so
not serious product that's the part i'll
switch out
and then over here just to make sure i
don't confuse it i'll have
two k plus one times
two okay is that all right so now the
part that i'm switching out
is here all right so now by assumption
it's equal to this
let's see here 2 to the k outside of odd
numbers
that times 2k plus
1 times two and
hopefully you can see now we're almost
there what's the target we're aiming at
this is what we want okay so the first
thing you can see is this two where's it
gonna go
it's gonna go with the other two that's
where this k
plus one comes from okay so that's good
this two will go all the way over there
and become k plus one
when you have a look at this thing one
by three by five by blah
right remember i drew your attention to
the fact this is not just any
uh sequence of numbers uh progression of
numbers they're the odd numbers
right and when you get two k minus one
two k plus one
is just the next odd number right does
that make sense
it goes up by two so it goes to the next
one and so what you've got is this
right can you see actually i was a bit
sneaky i wrote those down because i knew
i'd need it for later
okay so this part here is already
equivalent i just need to put this
inside the big square brackets
and that's it so one three five
two k minus one two k plus
one and that's it that's that's the form
i wanted to arrive at
okay so that's equal to the right hand
side
and now you make your explanation by the
principle of mathematical induction
let's see here where's it for one two
three
okay so one of my cool things about
induction is
uh when you look at this i know the
first time i saw this um
the program hasn't changed all that much
since i went through 10 years doesn't
change that much in maths anyway
i looked at it and i bought i was like
what do you do with that it's just a
mess
right but if you follow through with
your four steps
and what are we doing here just a bit of
algebra
moving things around factorizing a year
rate could do this if you taught them
the right steps
okay if you just gave them this
simplification there's nothing
dramatic there okay